pas
drôle à peine le jour s levé à peine la
nuit va
s'achever déjà ta main s glissé ch ch à
peine sortir du sommeiline àine tu
t'éveill que déjà tu cherches ma main
que déjà tu froules mes
rein l' blafarde par ta fen l'au
blafarde disparaît c'estes beau regards
par la fenêtre c'estes beau regards de
le jour
paraît à chaque jour recommencer à se
vouloir à se garder à se perdre à se
déchirer à se battre à ce crucifier
passe les vents et les marin 1000 fois
perdu déchirer 1000 fois perdu retroué
nous rest là et m on
estc et puis docilement si fragile tu es
la vague ou chemin noir tu es ma force
tu es ma
loi à peine le temps s posé printemps
hiver automne été tu t'en souviens
c'était hier printemp était automne
hiver à peine tu m'avais entrevu déjà tu
m'avais reconnu à peine je t'avais
souris que tjà tu m'avais choisi ton
indcile difficile et puis docile si
fragile je suis lav où tu te nois je
suis ta force je suis ta
loine dans le chamb séiss et l'ombre je
t'aperçois dans la pénombre tu me
regardes tu me gues tu
n'écoutes une porte qui FLA il ple le
bruit des Flames ailleurs le monde vit
ailleur et nous nous vivons là mon
cœur je m'enroule au près de
toi et tu
t'enroules auprès de
moi le temps passe vite simer à peine
l'avons-nous vu passenser que déjà la
nuit s Gliss c'est léger si
légèouche mon coup tu me man il fait lu
noir dehors ta bouche à mon cou je m'en
dans le sommeil je t'aime encore à peine
je suis
endormi déjà
tout ton corps mon corps s fait
lour bonsoir bonne nuit mon
amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]